but but if you're a governor how would
you approach the Second Amendment what
action would you take on it well
obviously will be become a section a
second amendment Sanctuary State I'll be
signing into law some of the bills I
actually have in thank you I like that
yeah and so I'll be signing into law I
don't know if I'll go as far as nukes
but clearly
it's specific would you be okay for
constitutional carry yeah absolutely and
actually I'm a co-sponsor of that bill
in the Senate great awesome we're
constitutional care in West Virginia
it's fantastic but it needs to be that
way and I don't even get why we have a
Second Amendment right and I have to pay
25 bucks to get a license every couple
years
are you kidding me additionally I have a
bill and I'm a prime sponsor of an
ascendant law and I hope the sign of the
law when I'm Governor I will actually
will prohibit law enforcement within
Pennsylvania from cooperating with the
federals if Joe Biden comes in to
enforce to enforce unconstitutional laws
man